here in the U.S a former Republican
political candidate is due in court
today he's accused of arranging multiple
shootings into the homes of Democrats
his name is Solomon Pina he's an
election denier and a trump loyalist who
already had a criminal record before he
ran for State office and he lost in
November Scott McFarland has been
covering this story Scott good morning
this is very troubling hey Gail good
morning to you three months ago Solomon
Pena was running a campaign for the
State House in New Mexico but police say
after his defeat he found accomplices
who riddled with bullets the homes of
local Democratic officials they say Pena
even tried to fire some of the shots
himself
in the weeks before his arrest Monday by
an Albuquerque SWAT team Solomon Pena's
social media feed was littered with
baseless claims of election fraud the
self-proclaimed Maga Republican lost his
race and then over a four-week period
police say he conspired with four
accomplices to fire shots into the homes
of two state legislators and two County
officials including Adrian barboa where
my home was shot right through my front
door four times out my back window right
through my living room and kitchen right
where I had just been playing only hours
before with my brand new grandbaby
barbowa tell CBS News Pena had come to
her home weeks earlier to insist she
decertify election results and doorbell
camera video shows Pena going to another
home looking for one of the other
Democrats he allegedly targeted my name
is Solomon Pena can I speak with DeVoe
in their report police say photo show
Pena with one of the alleged accomplices
and that individual with multiple guns
and ammunition and that pain yet paid
one of the alleged Shooters five hundred
dollars they also say Pena urged the
many hired to be more aggressive and to
shoot lower into the houses and to do so
earlier in the evening when targets
would be less likely to be laying down
and police say Pena personally took part
in at least one of the shootings but
that is gun jammed Tim Keller is the
mayor of Albuquerque well certainly if
it's happened here it has the potential
to happen anywhere in America and that's
a terrible thing we've got to understand
that even if we disagree even if we're
in different parties it should never
ever be violent and so this definitely
is essentially
verifying I think people's worst fears
about where America is at
police say in one of the shootings a
state lawmaker's ten-year-old daughter
woke up to Bullet debris hitting her in
the face this incident comes as there's
growing concern about threats against
lawmakers not just here in Washington
but all across the country mate
senseless violence Scott thank you